you know way to ease you guys into this
I'm just gonna say it
that was intense
[Music]
so whiplash is a movie starring miles
teller he's a drummer he gets into this
music school there's this one music
class run by JK Simmons and you he knows
if he gets into there this guy could
change his life like JK Simmons is one
of those teachers where you know you're
gonna go places under his welcome and
overrule and he gets into JK Simmons
class and after that he realizes JK
Simmons is the most hardcore asphalt JK
said this is he reminded me of earlier
me from Full Metal Jacket a lot of his
dialogue and monologues in the movie I
want to know how much of it was ad-lib
how much not because JK Simmons is a
really quick guy you saw him is jonah
jameson you thought jonah jameson was
hard that's nothing that is zero miles
teller yeah Reed Richards can now go to
Peter Parker and be like you thought you
had the hard core JK Simmons you didn't
I did it's not even the verbal abuse
that JK Simmons gives miles teller in
the movie there's also a psychological
war play happening he's coming at him at
all angles verbally mentally he's just
tearing this kid down I've said this to
my friend was like JK Simmons in this
movie is my single favorite performance
of 2014 the hands down some of the
things he says like just like earlier me
from Full Metal Jacket you laugh you're
like oh god I'm an for laughing
about that what did you say the delivery
is just spot-on and what it does in this
movie is it builds a level of intensity
the likes of which I haven't seen often
example you know I watch a lot of movies
I've seen a lot of them in my life I've
seen hostage negotiations the grades
I've seen that zero dark thirty
I've seen people have to cut a certain
wire on a bomb otherwise the world's
gonna explode maybe not the world but
definitely a building definitely that
person's world and I had not bit my
nails as hard in any of them as I did
when this kid is up on stage for the
first time in JK Simmons is like don't
this up I'm like Crimson Tide style
guru
the tension in this movie winds up like
a guitar string funny enough cuz it's
about this kid who plays drums usually
to create this kind of tension in a
movie there is something big happening
this is the kind of tension it's it's so
intense because it's so personal there
are a lot of subtle undertones in this
movies like one of them is what's the
point of doing this great thing and
being this great thing if you're not
having fun with it if you just hate life
if you hate your hobby what's the point
of doing your hobby what's the point of
being great at it regardless this kid
miles teller is chugging through this
class and JK Simmons is giving him hell
the entire time and you get where miles
teller is coming from we have all wanted
something bad enough so bad in our lives
that we will put ourselves through hell
than wear ourselves down to the bone
literally to get it if you have it don't
worry you will then you'll know what I'm
talking about
the only flaws in this movie are zero
the answer is none flaws folks it's as
simple as this the movie itself is
simple it's about a kid who's a drummer
who wants to be the best drummer
possible and a teacher who's a dick who
wants to push his students to be the
best musicians possible and these worlds
are colliding and somehow you're gonna
project yourself into this movie you're
gonna be like I had a boss like that or
at a teacher like that I knew someone
like that I know someone like that it's
gonna sink its hooks into you and it's
not gonna let go this was the movie the
more I think about this movie the better
it gets whiplash is not a fast paced
movie there's no Battle of five armies
but there's an ambitious main character
played by a really good actor even miles
teller holy I can't say whether or
not this Fantastic Four movie that's
gonna come out is going to be good I
don't know but I can't say they don't
have a good actor playing Reed Richards
you have a great antagonist JK Simmons
kills it it's just one of those things
where you look out of your like cave
Johnson the things you're saying
honest-to-god whiplash absolutely is
awesome tacular
I'll say this is one of those movies if
you have anxiety problems and don't like
it when someone is giving someone else a
lot of grief you're like empathetic to
that you might just raise something in
you where you just want to punch JK
Simmons in the face and probably be
worth watching anyway because that's
probably what the movies going for just
be warned it's in there that might be a
negative for you are so wit Blash have
you seen it what did you think about it
wherever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]